please can I bring some of my sister's
out here tonight
how'd you pull that all they said I was
weird but music told me not to listen to
them okay how was it being a part of
that it was incredible I'm having so
much fun I feel so blessed I feel
grateful I've been a part of the Grammy
community for 10 years now and just to
be here to celebrate all these beautiful
artists is wonderful and I'm just happy
for everyone and I can't wait to perform
it reminds me where I come from but it
also reminds me of all the places that I
can go music has always been the one
place we can all feel truly free it was
beautiful beautiful when she was
Alicia's brainchild she wanted to show
unity she wanted to give good energy and
great vibes to the nya and it was a
perfect way to do it we express our pain
power and progress through music whether
we're creating it or just appreciating
it but here's what I know every voice we
hear deserves to be honored and
respected Jada how how amazing was that
moment and how do I keep the secret you
know she's a mistress of ceremonies and
she was asking you know she wanted to
have a special moment
and so we had to keep it on the low
especially because I forever first lady
was here so for security purposes we had
to I was just well I was just with you
Friday and I was gonna be like oh wow I
know I was like oh hey you didn't know
why I was gonna be here I couldn't cool
is it the response that you get and how
this starts with bringing people
together this moment that's what
humanity is about coming together we all
need each other right and so it's just
about us treating everybody with respect
and coming together and celebrating all
the blessings that we all have no matter
what right yeah and it was really nice
to be able to see old friends on the
stage you know from the Motown Records I
wore out on the south side to the who
run the world songs that fueled me
through this last decade music has
always helped me tell my story every
story within every voice every note
within every song that right ladies what
a great surprise